stealing this hear how you sound yeah
dude stayed a pretty late editing blog
number three I know I said it wasn't
going to do that but whatever anyway
then I had to wake up really early the
next morning and then the following
night I was up really late because we
went out to go see in Q perform marine Q
from the podcast is so amazing anyway I
finally got a great night's sleep last
night I just woke up my brain is kind of
like scrambled but luckily I know a cure
for that all right let's go
how are you good how are you how are you
good how are you
yes I'm in the kids are good good you
don't mean it all your stuff is so
amazing that good luck sure you keep
fighting I am gonna I am and it's an
it's inspiring you know I'm glad you're
sharing your story it's powerful right
not bad not great either kind of an
appropriate metaphor for this vlog the
best part of that whole experience was
running into my friend Shannon ultra
Shannon Shannon for our griefer she's an
absolute legend in the ultra running
world she's done incredible things she's
run bad water like I don't know how many
times but like a lot and I think she's
the first I know she's the first woman
maybe the first person I'm not sure I
gotta look it up but to do a double bad
water crossing which is a 270 mile
footrace like she's incredible amazing
amazing person so it's great to
reconnect with her she's going through a
lot of stuff right now
I suggest picking up the latest issue of
trail runner magazine trail magazine I'm
not sure exactly what it's called but
there's a whole profile story about her
alright busy day first stop
office that's pretty cool all right I
got about two hours to deal with the
necessary evil that is email and to
record the podcast introductions for
Monday's show with Jack Canfield who is
a self-improvement author he's the
Chicken Soup for the Soul guy he's
written like 500,000 New York Times
bestsellers so don't have a lot of time
got to get it done
all right got it all done next stop
Hollywood garage
you
how's it going oh man I ever i'ma get my
dad high res on proper bridge that's got
Matt going good well this is trapper
trapper Ted Chinese nation
what hey hang out Walters not bark here
Oh how many you got ten two cats and two
dogs so excited about this man thanks
for doing it yeah of course man yeah
member people asking me about you hear
podcast before realizing that I knew
everybody said a couple times like you'd
ever met Joe ever he's got a [ __ ]
podcast somebody yeah I'm trying to be
that guy
I don't classify your podcast now so
many questions for you know what for you
just to talk with my dad on the way over
here and I was just thinking like how is
so good at stealing this hero you sound
yeah dude perfect search so quick came
here man I really know man it's uh it's
more fun for me because then I get to
see you like I don't share I've and
everything like that I I write your AR
in Rock n got Steve we got Ted have you
ever done a podcast before never done a
podcast wall job I got so many questions
for you two for me
yeah absolutely I mean c'mon see what's
it like to be steve-o death add the
depths of my alcoholism and drug
addiction you know like there's never a
point when I ever really [ __ ] on my
family well I think that that that you
know behind all the insanity you know
lives a pretty sweet kid you know we
don't know each other that well but I
know you a little bit like I know I know
what you like when the cameras off and
sure I know you're a lot more grounded
you know shockingly more grounded than I
think people would imagine I think
that's fair saying I should also sad
thank you for the kind words it's
appreciated right and we've known each
other for going I managed to turn eight
years sober right
science s amazing I mean I guess has
probably we probably met I was about in
about a year yeah I think that's I think
that's about right each other you know
somewhat peripherally for a good seven
years but yeah yeah sure I listen to the
Maron interview the other day and it was
it was before you got back to me and I'm
like man what am I going to talk to this
guy about he just just that whole thing
with Mark and then you're like I want to
have my dad on the podcast and I was
like that's genius like goes perfect
like this has never happened before so
this is it's never happened before
because I considered you to be an
authority I'm not just a vegan lifestyle
but health and nutrition in general so
much that I kind of hope that then we
can get into a little bit of a
discussion that then might influence and
the old manda to be a little bit more
careful about about what he doesn't
already anybody brought up my lifestyle
my health like my writing I might have
inferred my addiction I just Barney I've
turned really really harsh really cold
really fast and I had to shut down by
anything I was just so in such a bad way
that
and effectively burned all the bridges
in my career and it came like like quite
truly just a nasty person I think it the
way that we treat others is a pretty
pure reflection of how we feel about
ourselves flow of happiness and
fulfillment needs to cease to come from
the value of Stevo the commodity of the
entertainment industry and really needs
to begin to come from from inside Steven
Glover and without external validation
and that is sort and you were described
as having hobbies interests and make
yourself happy in the words of JFK let
me tell you this above that you've got
interests of depth that you don't know
about well help help me
Stevo podcast over he was great man and
then we went on a hike with his dad and
his dogs afterwards which was really
nice his dad was pretty cool he was very
engaging really those guys live on
different planets and it's so
interesting that they have such a close
relationship there many ways are so
different but then the more you talk to
them and the more we kind of play out
into it the more you realize like
they're more similar than you imagine
I think the coolest thing about the
podcast today is we saw a really
different side of Stevo it was much more
conversation with Stephen Glover than it
was with Stevo the performer I can't
wait to share the full episode with you
guys that was a pretty special yeah
definitely
Stevo was amazing that was such a cool
experience and it has me reflecting back
on this whole podcast journey that I've
been on I started the show about three
and a half years ago in a warehouse in
kouhai without any agenda whatsoever and
now it's become this whole thing in the
last few months alone I've interviewed
Arianna Huffington Russell Simmons and
people actually reach out to me in fact
I just got an email the other day from
Steve Case the founder of AOL who wants
to do the show which is like completely
insane so how does this happen well I
can tell you that it certainly didn't
happen because of some kind of plan and
it didn't happen because of some growth
hack or shortcut that I took I started
the podcast because I was inspired I was
inspired to just create something I
wasn't sure quite what but I started it
and I kept going I showed up for it and
that is the secret to the success of
this podcast I just focused on trying to
make the best show that I possibly could
to do it consistently and to give myself
permission to allow myself to fail and
to stay out of the result so much about
life is just showing up I have a
screenwriter friend of mine and when he
talks about writers and writing he
always says that the writers that make
it are the ones who refuse to give up
the ones who just keep writing after
they write a script they don't sit
around and wait to see if it sells or
how people respond to it they just start
writing the next thing and that's great
advice because you have no control over
the fruits of your Labor's the only
thing you have control over is the
content itself so I've started this vlog
with the exact same spirit that
motivated me to start the podcast this
isn't about how many views I'm going to
get or how many subscribers to my
channel it's about trying to
make something interesting something
that is a creative expression of my
authentic self my life it's about making
each vlog the best that I can within the
parameters of my busy life and it's
about a commitment to consistency it's
about giving myself permission to fail
and staying out of the results so if you
feel stuck in your life right now maybe
you have a creative impulse but you're
just afraid to try something new it's
probably because you are afraid of how
it's going to be received or because you
don't have it all figured out yet or
most likely because you're afraid to
fail but to engage in that thinking
that's the failure so my advice just
begin